just one day after calling kim
jeong-hoon
smart funny and a great person Donald
Trump is so upset with Canadian Prime
Minister Justin Trudeau that he's now
going to be punishing the people of
Canada Trump was interviewed by George
Stephanopoulos in the this was the same
interview we'll talk about later where
Trump ascribed to himself one of the
greatest human memories of all time
which was why he didn't need to take any
notes during that meeting with Kim
jong-un during the same interview Trump
said that he is just so displeased with
Justin Trudeau's recent press conference
that he is going to make it cost a lot
of money for the people of Canada he
learned you can't do that you can't do
that said Trump speaking about Justin
Trudeau we have simultaneously direct
threats to the people of one of our
great allies Canada and compliments all
around for a brutal dictator Kim jong-un
who has his own family members murdered
in cold blood what does this do for the
prospects of renegotiating NAFTA which
Trump has campaigned on it's not gonna
help what does this do for Trump
standing for Trump sort of position
within the g7 which was already pretty
touch-and-go doesn't help and it's not
even totally clear what set Trump off
about the Trudeau press conference
Trudeau has been critical of the steel
and aluminum tariffs he said that Canada
isn't gonna be pushed around by Trump
but that's not an insult right it's it's
just saying we are a country and we can
make decisions and we're not going to be
pushed around it's notable only if the
assumption is Trump should be expected
to be allowed to push anybody who he
wants to push around around and I was
talking to some Canadian friends who
said yeah listen I don't agree with what
is being said by Donald Trump here but
this is great for Justin Trudeau and I
looked into the approval ratings for
Trudeau and as of just a couple of
months ago Justin Trudeau's party had
only a 44% approval which for Trump
would be a record high but for Trudeau
is actually quite low and Trump
attacking Trudeau and threatening
Canadians is actually a gift to
Trudeau's reelection chance
and I don't know if that's actually
welcomed by Trudeau or now I don't know
if he's aware of it but he has now set
up Justin Trudeau to not give an inch on
trade deals and to have Canadians still
support him and doing it right
if Trump hadn't attacked Trudeau and the
Canadian people Trudeau would actually
take some flak for resisting
renegotiating a trade deal or signing a
trade deal or whatever Canadians now are
gonna stand behind the guy even if in
the short term he makes decisions that
might not be the best decisions for
Canada Canadians are going to be
increasingly willing to say you know
what Trump went after him Trump went
after us and we stand behind Justin
Trudeau holding firm here because we
don't want him to be pushed around I
don't know what the future is of
Canadian US relations but what I do know
is that the contrast between how Trump
is treating Kim jong-un and treating
Justin Trudeau is unimaginable would
have been unimaginable a year ago two to
three years ago and I think that this is
probably a good thing for Trudeau yeah
my sense is that this will certainly
backfire on Trump because Canadians seem
a lot more liberal than us here in the
United States and what Trump is really
saying is that Trudeau doesn't care
about his own people so much because
he's going to let them be victims of a
trade war sure contrast that to what he
said about Kim jong-un at the summit
which is that Kim loves his own people
you can't really make that argument when
the guy has gulags his killing his own
people the guy who's killing his own
family members
forcing famine and starvation upon his
own people and running one of the most
brutal totalitarian regimes according to
trump loves his people but Justin
Trudeau apparently is indifferent to the
Canadian people because he quote
insulted Trump
I guess merely by saying he's not going
to be pushed around this is a new era of
American diplomacy even though you can't
really call it that and geopolitics and
consider once again right this is what I
keep going back to the contrast between
our relationship with Canada and North
Korea Canada has teams in our sports
leagues North Korea sent otto warmbier
back to us in a coma
and Trump is friendlier over the last
week with Kim jong-un than he is with
Justin Trudeau Trudeau might actually
get more respect from Trump if he
decided to start developing nukes
forcing starvation upon the Canadian
people and having his uncle murdered or
something like that because that's what
Kim jong-un has done and it's getting
compliments for Trump it is the era of
the United States of America embracing
North Korea and Russia and Turkey while
seemingly deliberately ruining our
relationships with the European Union
and Canada and Mexico I guess this is
what they meant by Trump would be an
unconventional president or something is
that what we can say yeah it just seems
like he's taking all these positive
relationships with Canada with it you
for granted which you can never do right
you can never lay off the gas I think
Trump aswer argue though that you have
to keep your friends close and your
enemies closer that's apparently what
he's doing now they would argue that now
because it can be used to defend what
Trump is doing they would not have
argued that under Obama or under
Democratic presidents that's for sure
send me your thoughts and my question is
and this is not a rhetorical question
what the hell is going on that's my
question I'm on Twitter at D Pakman the
show is on Twitter at David Pakman show
and I look forward to hearing from you
with with some analysis as to how to
interpret what we're seeing at this time
I have both exciting and sad news and
it's the same news and it really depends
on your perspective
Sarah Huckabee Sanders Donald Trump's
latest press secretary is going to be
leaving the administration by the end of
the year not the most vile member as
I've said before just because she lies
constantly but because she seems to
truly relish her belligerent lying and
manipulation of the press corps and
she's one of the most visible members of
the Trump administration and she's going
to be quitting according to a CBS News
report that by the end of the year
Sarah Huckabee Sanders will be gone and
this is a major blow to Donald Trump
first of all it's a major blow because
she's one of the main liars in his
administration one of the most public
facing distorter --zz for this
administration is Sarah Huckabee Sanders
and
she's there to try to sort of soften
Trump's public missteps but this is also
big news because it's yet another major
staffer quitting and you might say well
David that's no big deal
Sarah Huckabee Sanders leaves they'll
just promote deputy press secretary Raj
Shah to the secretary position
unfortunately Raj Shah is also going to
be quitting according to that same CBS
news report he hasn't picked an exact
date but he will also be going bye-bye
this is the continued implosion of the
Trump administration and Sarah Huckabee
Sanders she actually didn't negate the
truth of the report she just said she
hasn't said anything like that she
tweeted yesterday after the CBS story
broke quote the CBS News know something
I don't about my plans in my future I
was at my daughter's year-end
kindergarten event and they ran a story
about my plans to leave the White House
without even talking to me I love my job
and am honored to work for the President
of the United States nothing in that is
a denial right she's not denying that
she's quitting she's simply saying she
hasn't been asked about it for the
report arguably they didn't need to
because she probably blabbed to so many
people at the White House that she's
leaving that it got leaked to CBS and
then they're reporting on it it's
possible that she's quitting because she
realized that her non-stop public lying
is both immoral and not good for the
country I don't think it's particularly
likely I think that it's something she's
just sick of the schedule or it's time
for her to move on I know she has at
least one young kid maybe two I don't
think it's any kind of grand realization
that she's been participating in the
takedown of American ethics for months
by her participation here I think she's
just sick of it he just realizes it's
time to go but it would be surprised if
she decided to stick around for a
January in February of 2019 yeah just
despite CBS to call them fake news who
will take the job that's a question I
have right because this is really a
position that has not been great for the
people that have done it Sean Spicer
his first day on the job the day Donald
Trump was inaugurated Sean Spicer
embarrassing himself by going out there
and lying about it was the biggest
inauguration crowd ever and it wasn't
he left Sarah Huckabee Sanders came in
she was able to pick up smoothly when
she took over for Sean Spicer and I was
thinking that she lies so much we can't
even trust her to tell the truth about
her quitting right she could be walking
across the White House lawn carrying
boxes of her stuff and she might say
fake news as a real problem and reports
have been misleading like she we can't
actually trust her to tell us the truth
about whether she's going to be quitting
or not we're just gonna have to wait and
see yeah I remember Sean Spicer strategy
was always apologetics and making the
story about him right messing up so
badly at the job that he took the focus
off of Trump for a second Sarah Huckabee
Sanders more obfuscation yeah not
answering questions so I don't know who
the new press secretary will be but I'm
sure we'll grow to love them too I would
love to actually see Sean Hannity become
the press secretary because Owens or
Candace Owens yes that would actually be
even more interesting and the most
interesting thing here is not about
another major staffer quitting that's to
be expected it's been an administration
that has a real problem with that for me
it's the role of the press secretary
right I understand that the job of press
secretary is you've got to put the best
possible spin on what the White House is
doing you make everything seem planned
and sober and well-thought-out
if you're defending an administration's
agenda and that's your job there will be
some distortion there will be some
debunk talking points but Sarah Huckabee
Sanders is sort of a special case for me
in that she has this ability to brazenly
and proactively cover up what Trump has
done and said through demonstrable lies
and deception she should be ashamed of
herself
based on her participation in this the
way I hope Sean Spicer is neither of
them realistically is actually
embarrassed by their behavior but this
is an administration that has set such a
low bar for press secretaries that I
hope that the I was just following
orders I was just doing my job excuse
will not be allowed to excuse their
behavior in the future because it has
set a truly new low standard it's a
pond-scum standard for what has been a
position that yes they do get involved
in the talking points and the rep
tition but not in this brazen and
proactive way send me your thoughts
david pakman.com slash re d di t quick
break back after this let's talk about
what's going on in Canada and in
Singapore before flying to Singapore for
today / tomorrow depending on which time
zone we're thinking of today / tomorrow
summit with North Korean leader Kim
jong-un Donald Trump stopped in Canada
for a g7 meeting it was previously the
g8 Russia of course no longer part of it
so it's the g7 Trump wants Russia back
in we'll talk about that separately
every aspect of Donald Trump's presence
was an embarrassment to the United
States there's really no other way to
say it trump showed up late he insulted
a variety of world leaders and left
early later sending subsequent insulting
tweets one such tweet about Canadian
Prime Minister Justin Trudeau Donald
Trump saying Prime Minister Justin
Trudeau of Canada acted so meek and mild
during our g7 meetings only to give a
news conference after I left saying that
u.s. tariffs were kind of insulting and
he will not be pushed around very
dishonest and weak our tariffs are in
response to his of two hundred seventy
percent on dairy Trump then gave a
bizarre rambling press conference that
was completely incoherent during which
he slammed CNN as fake news and said all
sorts of other things that made
absolutely no sense and then upon
leaving on his way to Singapore he
tweeted that he disagrees with the
communique that was sent out wrapping up
the entire summit saying quote based on
Justin's referring to Justin Trudeau
based on Justin's false statements at
his news conference and the fact that
Canada is charging massive tariffs to
our US farmers workers and companies I
have instructed our US representatives
not to endorse the communique as we look
at tariffs on automobiles flooding the
US market he claimed that our
relationship with allies is a 10 and yet
he's sending out insulting tweets about
our allies and then most interestingly
just in terms of the like the
flavor and color of the thing the
pictures that have been released are
truly embarrassing I mean really
indicative of a total and utter cuckold
REE check out pictures of Trump during
the summit versus Obama during a recent
similar summit you see at the top of
your screen Donald President Obama
rather in control in command clearly
respected as appear by other world
leaders and at the bottom of the screen
you see this picture of German
Chancellor Angela Merkel looking like
she's indignantly lecturing the little
kid at the table who won't eat his
broccoli meaning Donald Trump himself
and hilariously Donald Trump is known
for these handshake games that he plays
to sort of assert dominance whether it's
with Japanese leader Shinzo Abe a or
many others he tries to kind of jerk
them around with his handshake and
French President Emmanuel macron
dominating Trump in the first picture
I'm showing our video audience you see
Donald Trump clearly not in control of
the handshake you see a manual McCrone
with quite a grip there on Donald
Trump's right hand and then in a
close-up of Donald Trump's hand taken
immediately after this you can actually
see the thumbprint and the print from
the Crone's fourth and fifth fingers on
Trump's hand this was just moments after
the handshake and I mentioned this last
thing I get that it's sort of a goof
handshake games are really stupid but
they're important to Trump and by his
own standards of what's important he
clearly lost the game to Emmanuel macron
but handshakes aside another
embarrassing appearance by Trump
willfully ignorant bragging about not
preparing for negotiations with Kim
jong-un the world moving ahead without
the United States and there are trumpets
that are reveling in this as if it's
Trump putting America first not taking
crap from world leaders it is abundantly
clear that the u.s. is just being
excluded and is not seen as the player
it once was on the world stage and if
you don't mind that then congratulations
I guess by some harebrained logic Donald
Trump is winning but the United States
is increasingly not a player in world
climate change discussions and why would
be--that's by Chuck Trump's choice
the dynamics of the g7 in Canada
confirmed that while Trump arriving late
was disrespectful and an inconvenience
his presence was also a bother and an
inconvenience to the adults in the room
including very clearly German Chancellor
Angela Merkel realistically the new
leader of the free world as well as the
leaders of Japan and France and Canada
and the u.s. is being relegated to a
lower tier in the context of
international leadership period if
you're at rumpus then you see that as
winning well then yeah I guess Donald
Trump is winning but by any sensible
assessment the United States has been
taken down several notches on the world
stage and the world is laughing at us
right and the cherry on top which is
what I want to discuss in more depth
next is the the shrapnel that came from
this diplomatic abortion ended with
Donald Trump threatening to end all
trade with American allies let's talk
about that next
if there is one statement that Donald
Trump made in and around the g7 summit
in Canada that stands out as
particularly outrageous especially
ignorant it's his threat to end all
trade with American allies period
leaving the g7 summit Donald Trump said
the United States might end all trade
with some of our closest allies if they
don't do what Trump wants and also told
the leaders of Britain France Germany
Japan Canada and Italy that there should
be no tariffs period between them and
the United States let's break this down
it is either stunning ignorance or an
empty threat let's assume for a moment
that it's not an empty threat that Trump
really is thinking of doing this and
he's ignorant to the repercussions let's
explore what that might be like
specialization okay the idea that
countries are better off not making
everything themselves that they use but
making some things and importing out
others okay this is a basic fundamental
tenet of economics there is a major
debate over trade policy there's debate
over tariffs over import-export policy
over economic isolationism about finding
the right balance for lots of economic
factors but the idea that countries are
better off
doing some trade with other countries at
least to some degree it's a really old
idea and it's not a controversial
economic idea at all the controversy
comes in when you want to start
considering ok well can we build a trade
policy that although it might make
products cheaper in our country it might
also leave our own workers with lower
wages right it starts to get complex and
it starts to get into gray area and I
apologize for punching the mic I'm just
so invigorated by this conversation that
we're having these are complex economic
issues but the concept of specialized
and trade to some extent is a tenet of
modern Western democratic economies
period and Trump's threat to end trade
with our allies is as dangerous as it is
ignorant so let's talk about Trump's
ultimatum Trump's ultimatum is remove
all tariffs or we might stop trading
with you altogether there are advocates
of totally free trade right and and if
you want to take Trump's belligerents
and kind of like ascribe some policy to
it the policy is totally free trade and
there is a major debate to be had over
free trade the problem is that Moke most
people who claim to want free trade
don't really want it they want a version
of so-called free trade that benefits
them but they still want subsidies and
tariffs where it benefits them as well
and there are almost no true advocates
of 100% free trade and for good reason
which is that it's not practical nor
realistic nor typically beneficial in
the long run but the real problem is
that Trump just doesn't understand trade
isn't zero-sum whatever your views are
on free trade or protectionism and there
is a lot of debate about it I understand
trade is not zero-sum and there are
benefits to trade in specialization and
there are also costs and the costs are
not always just money but also jobs and
for example American exports to Canada
support about 1.6 million American jobs
according to 2015 data is that worth
risking over a slight trade imbalance
with Canada apparently for Donald Trump
it is
this would be self-inflicted economic
destruction if Donald Trump ended trade
with all of our allies and my real worry
is that because so many of trumps
followers don't know anything about
economics they've already been
bamboozled by Donald Trump's campaigning
on we're gonna win trade deals again
they might have no reason to doubt him
and they'll save stop trade with our g7
allies sure why not
sounds like more of that America first
winning that Donald Trump has been
promising and I also don't have to tell
you by the way the irony of Trump on the
one hand demanding free trade but saying
that if we don't get it will mandate no
trade whatsoever which is like the exact
opposite of free trade free trade one of
the tenets of actual free trade is no
governmental barriers or regulations
that would stop the flow of goods in and
out of countries so Trump is saying I
want free trade so badly that I will end
free trade altogether if you don't give
me my version of free trade this is no
longer look at Trump he's so dumb right
he is potentially irreversibly damaging
relationships with allies but over
things that he thinks will be good for
the United States which will actually be
self-inflicted disasters I can't wait to
see the committed trumpets come up with
creative ways to defend this idea
because there's no actual economic
defense of what Donald Trump is
proposing here and the scariest part of
all of it as I've said before is that
not only will some trumpets hear this
ridiculous idea
I'd say he's watching out for us he's
doing the America first thing he still
has nearly a 40 percent approval rating
that is really the scariest thing about
all of this I encourage you to discuss
this story or any others from today's
show on our David Pakman show subreddit
which you can access at david pakman.com
slash our IDI di t quick break
Andrew Torres will join me next to
discuss can the president pardoned
himself or not so I had a dream last
night or I guess maybe early this
morning shortly before my alarm went off
and in the dream Donald Trump
had succeeded and he achieved a historic
tangible enforceable agreement with
North Korean leader Kim jong-un
not only for denuclearization but also
for the real substantive improvement of
the lives of North Koreans and in that
dream I was thinking Trump did it I've
been a big anti Trump guy but I got to
give the guy credit he did something
historic and almost planet altering in
scope but that was only a dream and then
I woke up and in my excitement I pulled
up news and read about what took place
at the summit yesterday early today
depending on what time zone were talking
about and it turns out that what we
actually got was exactly what I
predicted sadly a so called the Korea
agreement for completely vague and not
even remote Abul promises that are sort
of maybe going to look into actually
making a reality and I really hate to
say it but the meeting between Trump and
Kim jong-un is exactly what I predicted
it would be and I don't want that to be
the case I wanted it to be something
great we'll talk about that in a moment
to give you the flavor leading up to
this thing Donald Trump and Kim jong-un
met and they shook hands and we've said
before that Trump is sort of drawn to
the dictator types we've been saying
that for a while and even in this clip
I'm gonna play for you where they're
sitting next to each other
they seem almost like equals in some
sixth sense we'll check out some video
prepare yourself for the awkwardness but
it is very very odd take a look
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so with past presidents right Obama even
George W Bush the US president would
seem like the adult in the room the
person with authority the person with I
don't know some some sort of leverage in
some way compared to the North Korean
leader not with Trump
they really do seem sort of like two
mildly confused guys who were sitting
there wondering what's going to happen
next so anyway on to the negotiations
former NBA basketball player Dennis
Rodman arrived in Singapore shortly
before the negotiations began more about
that a little later Donald Trump and Kim
jong-un meeting for a few hours it was
just the two of them with interpreters
reportedly what do we know about what
was agreed to well we got an agreement
that is as I said before filled with the
same possible concessions that Kim
jong-un has previously agreed to and
vague statements from both Kim jong-un
and Donald Trump as an example Donald
Trump committed to providing security
guarantees at some point in the future
not have actually been announced so far
if I were him I don't know that I'd be
trusting Trump since he's lied and
reneged on so many things so far Trump
and Kim jong-un agreed to enter into a
an effort to build a lasting and stable
peace regime sounds lovely
not actually actionable in any way
sounds very nice conceivably really a
great thing but if no actual meaning
whatsoever especially when you consider
the number of times that North Korea has
said similar things the most notable
element of the agreement I think is that
Donald Trump said he would suspend
military exercises with South Korea and
that that is actually a real action
although there's questions as to whether
that's even the best path forward I
heard a military analysts say you know
more effective might have been to invite
North Korea to participate in the war
games in some way rather than to just
say yeah we're gonna end those we'll see
what happens and of course Donald Trump
saying that he believes Kim jong-un is
going to dismantle his entire nuclear
arsenal and this is where we really
really get into the meat of it right
it's been reported that Kim jong-un has
agreed to start the denuclearization of
the Korean Peninsula and the language is
important we don't know who does what we
don't know exactly what that means
because the document they signed says
literally just that the DPRK commits to
working towards complete
denuclearization of the Korean Peninsula
and the important language would be a
commitment towards complete verifiable
irreversible denuclearization right
we don't have that and asked more
directly whether Kim jong-un pledged to
actually get rid of his nukes Trump said
we're starting that process very quickly
and North Korea has done similar things
before several times and I've said many
times that the language of
denuclearization of the Korean Peninsula
can mean many different things for Kim
jong-un in the past for North Korean
leaders in the past it has meant
American forces leaving South Korea
altogether for the u.s. it has met North
Korea giving up every nuke that it has
South Korea has made it clear that North
Korea knows exactly what the United
States means by denuclearization but
they play coy with the language
deliberately so that is really the
majority of this thing and now Mike
Pompeo and the North Korean official are
going to be negotiating further I want
to be really clear here I was hoping for
success I was hoping for something
tangible there is no question that this
is a possible change in tone
but the real achievement of the summit
is that Kim jong-un got what he wanted
which is he met with an American
president he was treated like a normal
real world leader with reporting around
the world about this and Trump the great
deal maker got the same vague
commitments from North Korea as prior
presidents have received but he gave Kim
jong-un the photo-op and he allowed Kim
jong-un to get the worldwide attention
in exchange I wouldn't have this guy
help me negotiate a car lease he got
what everybody else has gotten but he
gave away a lot he succeeded in
legitimizing a dictator without getting
anything of new practical value while
giving a major propaganda win to North
Korea the the piece of paper they signed
is very similar to the 1994 agreement
will with Bill Clinton it's similar to
other agreements but Kim jong-un in the
end got the photo-op that he wanted and
the big boy meeting with an American
president so the most notable element to
me here is once again not only the
suspension by the u.s. of the military
exercises but also that Trump is at
least theoretically agreeing to provide
some security guarantees in the future
and that would actually be a major
change and the prudence of which can be
debated the prudence of which is
questionable because if you were Donald
Trump and you say I'm willing to provide
security guarantees that is once again
the type of at least pseudo commitment
that doesn't actually put Kim jong-un in
a position of having to do anything and
Trump is trying to make this appear as
though it is a major victory Trump is
bizarrely gushing over Kim jong-un
saying after the fact that Kim jong-un
is smart and talented and a really funny
guy this is more praise than Donald
Trump has recently given the Canadian
Prime Minister Justin Trudeau who's
presumably our ally and Kim jong-un is a
brutal dictator but he is smart talented
and funny in the eyes of Donald Trump
will this be good for Trump that's
actually a really interesting question
regardless of the fact that nothing
real and tangible was achieved by this
summit it still could be good for Donald
Trump's reelection chances it might even
be good for Republicans in November
because many Trump ists aren't going to
read past the headlines period they
signed a piece of paper there have been
months of talking this up people talking
about a Nobel Peace Prize for Donald
Trump and we ended with a document whose
value is merely that they are going to
have more talks but Kim jong-un now has
worldwide headlines for weeks and the
signal that Donald Trump sent is if you
acquire nukes and you threaten the world
and you brutalize your own people you
can earn yourself a face-to-face with an
American president to worldwide acclaim
you tell me what signal that sense if
you are other countries that are
starting to think you know maybe Kim
jong-un is on to something maybe we
should grab some nukes from whoever will
sell them to us and see how that works
for us extraordinarily dangerous and I'm
genuinely I don't relish this right I
actually wish I could come to you I mean
in my dream I was thrilled I had this
dream where Trump did it and I I was
actually saying I'm gonna have to go on
the show today and say this is a
historic and incredible achievement by
our president I wish I could come and
tell you that literally only in my
dreams did that actually take place
every once in a while truth gets out on
Fox News and usually it gets out because
Shepard Smith told the truth less
frequently truth gets out on Fox News
because Chris Wallace told the truth
other times it just slips out of
someone's mouth accidentally and what we
might in some ways even call in a
Freudian way Fox and Friends was
anxiously and excitedly reporting about
the arrival of their hero Donald Trump
in Singapore to make big boy
negotiations with Kim jong-un when Fox
and Friends weekend host Abbey Huntsman
I guess they sort of have like their D
team on the weekends I'm not really sure
Abbey Huntsman said that the two
dictators Trump and Kim jong-un would be
meeting the following day the two
dictators would be meeting Trump and Kim
jong-un here's the clip from Fox &
Friends
now there is the President of the United
States Donald Trump about to walk down
those stairs stepping foot in Singapore
as we await this historic summit with
the North Korean dictator Kim Jong hoon
man let me talk to us about this mom I
mean this is history we are living
regardless of what happens in that
meeting between the two dictators what
we are seeing right now this is history
correction Abbey the dictator and the
guy who would like to be a dictator are
going to be meeting and the apology came
later in the day from Abbey Huntsman
saying she wants to point out that
earlier as you know on live TV sometimes
you don't always say things perfectly I
called both President Trump and Kim Jong
hoon a dictator I did not mean to say
that my mistake so I apologize for that
was it a mistake Abbey or is this part
of the effort to condition the Fox News
audience to like dictators listen even
if there was collusion it wouldn't be
illegal listen even if Trump was a
dictator that's not necessarily a bad
thing as long as he's a conservative
dictator who we like
probably just a slip-up I'm mostly
joking but a very funny one Trump is not
a dictator he would like to be one he's
actually having a hard time getting
people to do what he wants especially
foreign leaders who are way smarter than
he is and I guess what we can say is in
the United States we still do have the
rule of law at least on paper and that
rule of law has stopped Trump from doing
some of the things he would no doubt
like to do and the path to dictatorship
is actually not so much set by the guy
who wants to be dictator but it's opened
by those who don't stop the would-be
dictator right and what I mean is it's
up to everybody else to prevent Trump
the dictator and to be clear I'm not
literally saying the u.s. is becoming a
dictatorship but it's a sort of de facto
Western democracy pseudo dictatorship
authoritarian paradise right that's
that's really what it is that Trump
would want I don't know that he
literally wants a dictatorship in this
sort of despot type of way maybe he does
but I don't I don't know and I was
thinking it's actually really working in
our favor that Trump doesn't know how
government works because if Trump knew
how government worked he would be way
better at manipulating it to his
advanced
and to the obvious detriment of the
American people and I'm reminded of a
bit of Edward R murrow's writing on this
Edward r murrow wrote as quoted by AM
Sperber in Murrow his life and times
quote if they deceived her confused
public is betrayed into creating or
allowing to be created an America in
which it loses faith democracy will not
survive very very appropriate to Trump
and more generally towards 2018 United
States of America and less away why are
we so worried about Trump speaking to
Kim jong-un anyway right
Trump's going to have a conversation
with one of the most dangerous people on
the planet and the worst possible
outcome after all there's only nuclear
war I don't know why anybody would
really be so concerned about that it's
gonna be fine I don't know why anybody
would be skittish about this meeting we
will know about very very soon send me
your thoughts I'm on Twitter at D Pakman
so let's reset Trump's lawyer Michael
Cohen
appears to be flipping as I told you his
lawyers are quitting on him he's the
target of multiple investigations it's
gotten so bad for Michael Cohen that
even his supposed unending love and
respect for Donald Trump isn't going to
keep him quiet and keep him from
flipping and cooperating with
investigators may be in multiple
investigations that's the sort of crux
of what's going on
so just as quickly as Michael Cohen's
future has been torpedoed Donald Trump
and his associates have started to build
this effort to discredit Michael Cohen
sort of shocking from the guy Trump who
supposedly is endlessly loyal to the
people that work for him right and it
started a couple of months ago much more
subtly for example Donald Trump on
Twitter thing was back in April said
quote the New York Times and a
third-rate reporter named Maggie
Haberman who known as a crooked Hillary
flunky who I don't speak to and have
nothing to do with are going out of
their way to destroy Michael Cohen and
his relationship with me in the hope
that he will flip they use non-existent
sources and a drunk drugged up loser who
hates Michael a fine person with a
wonderful family Michael is a
businessman for his own account lawyer
who I have always
like than respected most this is the key
part most people will flip if the
government lets them out of trouble even
if as Trump says it means lying or
making up stories sorry I don't see
Michael doing that despite the horrible
witch hunt and the dishonest media this
is laying the groundwork that when
people do flip they don't tell the truth
this is layer one of preparing to
discredit and smear Michael Cohen as
untrustworthy in his potential future
cooperation with investigators layer one
let's look at layer two Alan Dershowitz
who has by the way jumped completely off
the deep end defending Donald Trump
endlessly he wrote an op-ed some weeks
ago where he also started to sort of
preemptively cast doubt into future
testimony from Michael Cohen writing in
the hill it is doubtful that Cohen would
cooperate even if he has anything on his
client referring to Trump but
prosecutors often try to get lawyers to
sing against their clients to become
Canaries in order to save their own
feathers some flipped witnesses will
tell prosecutors anything they want to
hear in order to earn a
get-out-of-jail-free card they know that
the better their story the more leniency
they will earn so in addition to singing
they compose by making up incriminating
details listen when we talk about
torture
we know that torture is ineffective in
great part because the person being
tortured will say whatever they feel
they need to say to get the torture to
end right we've talked about that
endlessly Pat we know that they're
trying to say the same thing happens in
criminal investigations where when you
get a cooperating witness they will just
lie and make things up in order to get
themselves out of trouble and
potentially improperly incriminates
someone else this is a fantasy okay
number one investigators only even allow
a suspect to cooperate if they've
already determined that the suspect has
the knowledge and the information that
would be valuable to them in prosecuting
or in
dating someone that's higher up in the
chain they don't just offer anybody the
opportunity to get out of jail free as a
rule and our wits is saying here not
Giuliani and then you're allowed to say
whatever you want and then they go and
they file bogus charges against somebody
that is not how it works and in addition
to that when you flip and cooperate they
don't just accept everything you say at
face value they take your testimony and
then they look for evidence and then
they look to corroborate it the idea
that there is any analogy between
torture doesn't work because the people
will just say anything which is true and
cooperating witnesses can't be trusted
because they just make stuff up and get
people falsely indicted
it's a fantasy that's just not how it
works yeah it imagine typically how it
works is you'll have a criminal who is
lying in lying trying to get away with
what they've committed right and then
eventually they get caught and so they
have to come around and start telling
the truth they want you to deny that
logic that intuition that you have that
that's how the story goes yeah I just
try to flip it on its head but it
doesn't work and sources close to Trump
are now making it clear that Trump and
his cronies are ready willing and
absolutely almost eager to run a massive
smear campaign against Michael Cohen to
preempt the credibility of his eventual
flipping which at this point seems
imminent as I mentioned to you and the
truth is that the entire Trump is so
loyal narrative is only true as long as
you're willing to lie and cheat and
steal and most importantly protect Trump
at all costs
Trump expects loyalty from everybody
else but he's only loyal to you as long
as you're useful in protecting him and
when you're not not protecting him
anymore he throws you under the bus
right away and he's the exact type of
person that you deal with I was thinking
you know in high school maybe even in
college there's people that you don't
really like them but you continue to
hang around them and be nice to them
because they're popular or they give you
access to things or people that you like
and you want to be around them but most
people once they become adults do you
leave college you realize that the
toxicity of being around these people is
not worth it and you say you know what
I'm old enough that I don't need to be
around these people anymore and what you
have to understand is that the people
that are still surrounded
that are surrounding Donald Trump are
the people who never got out of the
high-school mindset of dealing with
toxic people because they're either
popular or wealthy or well-connected and
that actually gives us a really big
insight into the cult of personality
around Trump it's the people that in
high school were the sort of sycophants
that would just be around the popular
people to try to get the popularity
shrapnel they've never actually become
adults and they're still trying to be
around placating Donald Trump yeah you
were talking in the last story about how
Michael Cohen should maybe be on suicide
watch because he's gonna be in so much
trouble yeah you know if Trump the
person that he was such good friends
with is going to turn on him he doesn't
really have anyone left and he's not
going to be able to get that popularity
rubbed off on him so why would he stay
right and I think that that's the exact
thing that we're getting to the end here
for Michael Cohen send me your thoughts
I'm on Twitter at D Pakman the show is
on Twitter at David Pakman show
if I'm wrong if you think that Cohen is
fine he's not in trouble let me know why
because that's something that would be
truly shocking to me to hear